allison hulker boss i am so excited that
you invited me to be here because
i needed to get out of the house momma
needs a little break all right well good
we'll chill today we'll have a little
girlfriend time um you've also become
internet famous
after all the dance videos that you and
your husband twitch
and all your kids do as well i think
what people like about those videos is
it's pretty genuine it's just about
celebrating dance celebrating our love
and having a good time
there's a little something good about
freestyle am i right yeah
that's what you told us we're gonna take
you back way back in 2006 when we first
met you as a contestant on so you think
oh my goodness take a look right here
that's what i like about dancing
is doing improv and just getting up
there and you have no idea what's gonna
happen
that's the most amazing feeling in the
world when you accomplish it
what a throwback oh my i don't even look
like the same human
oh that was baby allison up there and
you've proven to us that dancing is
better with friends and family so
we have teamed up with you and visible
to show that
a wireless plan is better with friends
right absolutely
visible is the only wireless service
that gets better with your friends or
family
right now if you get visible's unlimited
wireless service
you can get it for five dollars a month
if you bring in a friend
or if you bring in 12 friends you can
get 12 months for 60 dollars so
it's a really cool new idea of looking
at your phone plan it's a great deal
and also what's really nice about it is
it's actually powered by verizon so
you're getting 5g
you know we could talk all day we really
could talk all day